so as always time then for the Press
preview at checking out Sunday's front
pages and tonight we'll see what's
making headlines with the journalist and
author Christina Patterson and columnist
at the article Ali Mirage a very good
evening to both of you we'll chat in a
moment after we've had a look at those
front pages for you beginning with the
telegraph reporting that the prime
minister is planning to continue her tax
cutting in a New Year budget that will
include reforms to income tax savings
and Child Benefits
the express leads with the Chancellor's
words that his tax cuts announced in the
mini budget this week are just the start
while the Sunday Times it says Liz trust
may be about to face her first cabinet
Rao and she plans to boost immigration
to tackle labor shortages and fuel
growth
The Observers at front page leads with
details of a pledge from labor leaders
kirstalmer to deliver a new era of
economic growth into turn Britain into a
green superpower before 2030.
the mirror reports on former football
manager Harry redknapp's wife's
difficult experience with covid
and just a reminder that you can scan
the QR code on screen during the program
and check out from pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch us discussing
them and to discuss them Christina
Patterson and Ali Mirage so lots to uh
discuss it's been a very busy few days
and we'll start with the Sunday Express
shall we Ally their headline Chancellor
you ain't seen nothing yet uh labor
accusing the government of course of
gambling with the country's finances the
government says the gamble is actually
very of high levels of Taxation which
stifle growth and deter investment Ali
which side are you on
well look I think the government's plan
is very clear it's very bold it's very
aggressive
um you can't say that uh they're not uh
throwing a kitchen sink at what they're
trying to do here but I do feel that the
think tank ideologues have taken over
the stable and I think there are two
issues with this I mean you've seen uh
the top rate of tax which was a rabbit
out of a hat that no one really expected
down from 45 to 40 percent uh you've
also got the basic rate gone down from
20 to 19 uh and other things happening
across the board here uh stamp Duty
going down other measures take being
taken on supply side reforms just RAM
Booster economy all very welcome but the
thing that worries me is really two
things one is the economics of this at
the moment you've got inflation just shy
of 10 you've got interest rates going up
some would argue that the bank of
England has not been aggressive enough
in increasing those interest rates uh
and that is all to try and dampen down
growth and on the other hand you've got
the government trying to engage age in
all sorts of stimulus measures to boost
growth I just can't see how that hangs
together on the economic side and then
on the politics of all this Jonathan I
just think optically it's very bad if
you are telling public sector workers
who are going for inflationary pay rides
is that there's no money in the pot to
give them those inflationary pay Rises
because you'll enter into a rage price
inflationary spiral and yet you're
cutting tax on the the top earners I
mean you know great for people like me I
I'll be sitting pretty but I think it's
completely the wrong thing and very
fiscally irresponsible when we've
borrowed 400 billion on covid and now
another 150 billion has been borrowed to
support people with energy bills quite
rightly but I just think where's all
this money going to come from I mean a
good I think I hope I'm wrong I hope
they do get the growth that they're
expecting but I'm very worried about
inflation and I'm also worried about
mortgaging our kids and our grandkids
future to pay for all this yeah I mean
that's exactly what they say isn't it
that growth will pay the bills but of
course no one can fall ask the future
Christina the front of the Observer at
starmer unveils green growth plan to
counter trust tax cuts labor Party
Conference of course starting in
Liverpool and what were your thoughts
when you when you heard this mini budget
well I I thought we've been kidnapped by
aliens I mean it feels like they have
you know we were in a car that was
lurching all over the place not
brilliantly I mean it was all looking
pretty judgy and suddenly some Maniacs
have taken over the wheel and are
driving us over the edge of a cliff
that's what it feels like I'm absolutely
terrified and I think if Tories won't
listen to think tanks and they won't
call I mean the idea this was a mini
budget or you know a fiscal statement is
like calling it a kind of special
operation as Putin did of his war in
Ukraine this is like ex blowing up the
entire economy and if they won't listen
to the think tanks who have said this
will literally only enrich the tiny
proportion population the top five
percent actually will be richer and
pretty much everybody else will be
poorer or or so have so little benefit
that will make almost no difference to
them taxes will by the way remain high
because they were um over the 12 years
of this Parliament moment of this Tory
government they have gone up and up so
although it is tax cutting for the very
rich it's not actually tax cutting for
the poor but the networks even if they
won't listen to economists even if they
won't expose it to the scrutiny of the
obr you would have thought they would
listen to the markets and the markets
have gone mad people like Crispin ode
who is you know a
story as you get hedge funder who by the
way has reportedly been betting against
the pound which is always nice shorting
um you know people are saying we might
reach parity with the dollar which would
be terrifying noriel rabini who um
predicted the financial crisis wrote a
book Black Swan he is predicting that
Britain will have to go cap in hand to
the IMF this is really terrifying stuff
and instead of listening to the market
so saying whoa you ain't seen nothing
yet but just starting as if this was
some kind of you know funfair where
they're going to have a lovely time this
is our lives and Futures and Bank
balances and savings and homes and jobs
yeah yeah
um today secure starmer refusing to say
whether he would reverse the tax cut
well look I think kirstama doesn't want
to reveal his hand early so early I mean
he's got two years to go I think Kirsten
at the moment needs to sit back uh he is
sitting back and waiting for this to
unfold there's been a lot of Tory uh
Blue on Blue infighting during the
leadership contest he now is like
probably hanging back to see how this
all plays out but certainly uh the labor
party is going to Champion the rights of
workers and look I I'mma died in the war
capitalist but even I understand that
you you're facing a potential Revolution
if you have a situation where too many
people in this Society do not feel they
have a stake in the capitalist system
and you've got strikes writ large with
even barristers For Heaven's Sake
striking uh asking for inflationary pay
Rises on the back of uh a rising energy
costs on the war in Ukraine so we have a
serious problem here inequality was
already increasing over well over a
decade I do understand where the
government's coming from in trying to
boost productivity because we have been
in a a stage of poultry growth and
falling real incomes for well over a
decade but I just think it's Reckless at
the moment where at the moment the
credit rating of the UK is double A
minus
that could be reviewed I mean the cost
of borrowing at the moment on a 10-year
guilt is 3.8 percent we need to borrow
money in markets to fund all this so
you've got massive borrowing huge
borrowing on one hand you've got massive
tax cuts the likes we've not seen since
the barber budget in 1972 for 50 years
look I mean I hope that they know what
they're doing I mean quasi's a very very
intelligent guy I mean look him up in a
look him up in a uh an academic Hall in
Trinity Hall who get a double thirst and
a PhD but the politics of this as well I
mean if you're a if you are a an MP
representing a northern seat how are you
going to sell this to your working class
Tory voters to fact you in 2019 for
breaking yeah yeah you make a very good
point in fact that's uh on the front
page of the Observer Chancellor risks
red wall votes uh say Tory MPS making
that very Point um and uh Christina just
back you mentioned this
um uh when you last spoke front page of
telegraph trust plans to cut taxes again
in New Year just explain this story
well I mean if anybody in this country
is uh earning anything by the time in a
few months time when a trust plans to
have a budget which may or may not be
exposed to obr scrutiny she's going to
bring her you know gleaming acts to
um you know yet more uh taxes apparently
including things like sugar taxes which
are really I mean I I think that's
disastrous obesity is an enormous issue
in this country not least for children
who are big consumers of fizzy drinks
there has been a lot of work since the
sugar tax was introduced and
manufacturers have reduced uh the amount
of sugar that does have an effect on
Obesity but this stuff takes a long time
this just looks like wrecking to me it
includes measures in supermarkets it's
as if they are literally saying we just
want capitalism red in tooth and and
Claw we don't care how unhealthy people
get we don't have any role to play in
people's lives I mean you know the idea
is that this is meant to be kind of
small state
um low tax small state but it's not
small state I mean we're already
spending we had the bailout from covid
which was necessary although extremely
badly handled with masses of big a big
or businesses making huge amounts of
unwarranted money from it and lots of
fraud involved and now we have the 150
billion energy bailout potentially which
instead of being
um partly paid for by
um windfall taxes on energy companies
that could well afford to pay it and
they have said they could well afford to
pay it taxpayers we you and I are going
to be paying for this for Generations
okay and now they're talking about
further Cuts so I mean honestly I feel
like we are in charge I'm sorry to use
this phrase but it feels like literally
the lunatics are in charge of the Asylum
okay and it's very frightening all right
uh we're out of time we need to go to a
break about uh plenty more to discuss in
a moment including the Sunday Times
focusing on Liz trustee's plan for more
migrants to boost growth uh discussing
that and more in a minute
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Christina and Ali still with us
front to the Sunday Times Ali has got an
interesting story
um another Liz truss plan this time
involving migration
well yes uh Liz truss wants to uh reform
the migration rules allow a lot more
people in uh seasonal agricultural
workers which makes a lot of sense but
also Broadband Engineers to reach this
uh Target of 80 to 85 percent of people
having
um access to uh uh fast Broadband by
2025 but also higher skilled workers
from the top 50 to 100 universities in
the world now this is all very
interesting because this is part of the
Singapore on Thames model that a lot of
people advocating for brexit were
pushing uh when we had that referendum a
few years ago and there was a real
distinction between those on the one
hand that were pushing for complete
liberalization Open Door immigration
policy and those on the other side that
were actually of the brexit argument
that was saying no one of the reasons
for the vote in favor of leaving the EU
was precisely to control immigration it
was 300 000 at the time and it was felt
that it was too high and the pace of
change and effects on public services
too great now there's going to be
apparently a row in the cabinet or at
least a robust discussion let's say
between suela Bravo and Kimmy badenoff
and even Jacob Reese smog who are not
convinced by this and Liz truss and
quasi cool thing on the other hand who
want to literally have a bonfire of the
migration rules and and let people in so
it's going to be interesting to see how
this one plays out yeah Christina
presumably this is one Liz trust policy
you are in favor of
and well not no not automatically no I
don't think it was worth leaving the EU
and causing all the havoc and heartbreak
and wrecked businesses and then in order
essentially I think I mean it was
absolutely evident that a huge part of
the motivation for many people and was
that this sense that there were too many
well they didn't like freedom of
movement they didn't like EU migrants
that were coming in and they wanted to
stop it and now of course where I live
um there is so many restaurants and
businesses that can't get the staff
there are cafes that close early
um the Farmers can't get the the workers
and incidentally Ali mentioned High
skills and so on but actually this
includes
um letting in agricultural workers
presumably not from the EU I mean
presumably they're all going to be from
anywhere except the EU since they went
to such enormous efforts to exclude them
from the EU and as they say that's
destroying or severely damaging many
businesses in the process so look I'm
I'm all in favor of controlled
immigration I'm not in favor of you know
unilaterally open doors to everyone
because that would open the doors to you
know potentially the entire population
of the planet and that's clearly not not
you know possible or sustainable or a
good idea but this just is bound to
introduce more red tape because you
can't just open your doors it means
schemes it means visas it's complicated
and I I can imagine it would be
extremely irritating to people who did
vote for brexit because they would think
hang on we were voting against
immigration and now you're increasing it
and by the way immigration is increasing
anyway not from the EU but from outside
the EU which you know I don't know if
that's what people who voted brexit
wanted but that's what's happening so I
mean you know it's an admission again
that that from Liz Charles who was as we
know a very enthusiastic remainder and
then became a born-again brexiteer that
limiting immigration in the way that has
happened with brexit was not a good idea
because we've lost a lot of skills let's
leave that there because we've only got
30 seconds left I want to do one more
story if we can Ali you can choose both
on the front of the telegraph military
numbers growing or more Bankers coming
to London
well I like the bankers coming to London
thing because it made me laugh I mean
look the whole thing about reducing the
tax on uh reducing the bankers bonus cap
abolishing that and reducing the top
rate of tax is not something I agree
with at all because I think the octaves
of it are terrible but it did make me
laugh that now people in Edinburgh are
the government there is going to be
under some pressure because it's got a
46 top rate of tax and now at the top
rate of tax in England is going to be 40
so there's going to be some pressure on
Nicholas sturgeon to take some action if
she's not going to have an exodus of um
bankers and people in the financial
sector from Edinburgh to London which
made me smile yeah it's an interesting
interesting take on things isn't it and
we'll perhaps talk about military
numbers uh in the next hour thank you
both very much great to chat and we
shall see you again in half an hour so
right now let's take a look at the
weather